more nutrition truths that Wellness
influencers don't want you to know no
food or supplement can boost your immune
system if it did we would all have
autoimmune disease
eating a single piece of bacon is not
equivalent to smoking for cancer risk
your body doesn't just switch to Fat
storing mode after 8 pm
all the butter isn't clean and peanut
butter isn't junk in fact peanuts
actually have more protein per ounce
avoiding vegetables because the
anti-nutrients is like avoiding water
because of hydrogen the way that most
humans eat them they're really not a
concern
fast food versus fed exercise doesn't
actually make a significant impact on
your weight
and just because it has health benefits
doesn't mean that more is more I'm
looking at you I'm in moms which of
these nutrition truths are going to make
the most influencers mad